to going Riley our intern likes to when
I say okay Riley let's go he makes it go
live and he's like okay we're live but I
caught him because I was watching the
feed Oh what's up everybody
I'm all alone today I'm all alone here
at stream Koko Beth has better things to
do so you know what I did I put on my $8
shirt which is real stretchy that I got
in New York for $8 so by the way this
just goes to nothing this is skin so
boob out we got a boob pocket today and
and I came here and we're gonna play a
little game then I kind of it reflects
on me being alone today it's called
adrift with the one so I guess it could
be adr1ft hey Abbi Abbi Kirk is crying
in the chat right now why why is that
hey arson rape rape 3ra EEP tell them to
me I said that in a really bad way so
we're off to a great start
let's just play shall we this is why I
need somebody else with me because you
know I'm a nightmare person we have last
week off I hope you all had a fantastic
but a little bit depressing week because
there was no Conan so I hope you missed
us aw ma MB TV I will say what's up
online instructor hand for administra
series for version 1.6 trainee commands
gun Oshima Alex mission Hardeman
aerospace North Star for mission active
date 29 September 20 35
well there's my weed floating around
right there on the right to invert EBA
control system access options menu you
know what I got see something I'm more
into like a female voice does that make
me a misogynistic or Eevee a look yeah
we don't need this man
we don't need video game tutorials or
you like look around I think it's like a
video game tutorial where you have to
look around is a lot like when they tell
you to put your seatbelt on on a plane I
get it maybe a to get off and thrust or
their we understand we've been in a car
since 1950 we understand Jonathan
Sanchez we're playing this game called a
drift or adr1ft and they they try to
make it cool by putting a activate EBA
propulsion boost got it okay here's my
weed let's get a close-up look at my oh
can I grab my weed Can I grab my weed oh
geez
perform a VA ascend yeah I got it I got
it man
hey what's up mash Lazzara good to see
you I'll put the overlay on the bottom
hey could you put the overlay at the
bottom perform a v8 descent okay got it
you could just tell me all the buttons
at once the drift you know I look at
this ball let's hit it ooh
Henry activate EPA propulsion break
alright got it
yep doing it
all the way no one has tied anything
down in the space t-shirt
everything's just floating around
perform a mile roll whoo here we go
let me guess the roll right is this way
is that we're gonna tell me next
yep guys in space no one can hear you
scream
also no one can hear you cry which is
why I'm trying to move to space so I
don't keep annoying my neighbors by
weeping all the time hey what's up
Justin gomez good to see you thanks for
joining us
put my FaceCam at the bottom it's been
done activate a PA stabilize that gets
us back to we're supposed to be okay
three hours later we've finished the
tutorial oxygen levels are monitored via
IV a hug oxygen meter all right
oh I see okay on the right there what is
this it's a salad or displays a space
salad sarmat mr. a mister we don't know
if it sucks yet activate EBA environment
scan
oh the Antelope says I don't think it's
misogynistic it just factors in who
taught you at a young age predominantly
met ordered online aerospace I had a lot
of females in simulation so complete
that's why I don't respect you and says
but I do respect women that's why the
patriarchy is a joke and I know with me
saying this is gonna light up the chat
the patriarchy is a joke and women rules
there there we go
a feminist deal with it
they should have talked about space
Glenn they should but here's the thing
man you got to be careful about what
Taco Bell what space Taco Bell is gonna
be on the men you know what the Taco
Bell in space what's gonna be on the
menu
definitely not hard crunchy tacos all
that oh that's just gonna float away you
know mostly burritos Crunchwrap Supremes
am i excited the baseball season nope I
couldn't care less don't care about
baseball it's just a bunch of people
hitting hitting balls with clubs you
know let's get lit all right Joseph you
first so glad this is a thing now well
thank you Ryan Cobra all right so where
am I supposed to go is the next question
can we go out into space let's try it
here we go slowly but surely
oh dude we're going on to space let's do
it
Oh guys best thing about space you don't
need air conditioning it's so cold you
just crack a window and it gets right
down below freezing before you know it
you'll also die but that's what it is
Anthony likes turtles Thank You Anthony
I will say the chat never boring you
guys are never boring
where's Conan well Conan's back from
Japan who's in Japan all last week with
Jordan apparently if you saw any
snapchats or instagrams we did and so
far Conan has kicked me four times today
I can't he's like bleh and yelled down
the the office and so our office is
really long and so I walked down there
and then he was just like wall and
started like doing this he kind of
attacks lately Conan is stop punching me
and he's just moved into kicks and it's
a lot like an emu attacks you know it's
vicious it kind of comes in you know the
kicks are different cuz you don't see
him coming because they're coming up and
he's got such long legs he's mostly leg
he's basically like head if you you know
that that that that song head shoulders
knees and toes you don't need to do the
shoulders part it's just head knees and
toes knees and toes
that's all Conan that's like Conan's
theme song so yeah and you don't I'm not
used to this coming up it just comes so
quick plus he grows his toenails out
really long like this and he doesn't
wear shoes in the office so it's kind of
like their talents coming on I'm just
kidding about that survive were located
initializing EBA Club this is a bunch of
kicks today and then I told him about my
most recent date and then he said get
out of my office never come back
whoa what's happening
am I really excited oh my god
I think I'm orgasming as an astronaut oh
wait
looks like stuff semester oh this games
kind of like gravity all right don't let
go of that dude oh geez
what happened to the thing where I was
just flying around all peacefully also
are there you know I like subtitles guys
where the subtitle says the question yes
perfect
that's not an oxygen link I had some of
that space Taco Bell who okay here's a
bottle of oxygen okay I'll drink perfect
cassowary what's a cassowary Andrew
Costello maybe watch anime alert some
new kick attacks I think that's what
happened by the way
so everything's effed what's up
Miguel if I put it in temple switch yes
grand thief I've plated its dough I'm
having a Sandra Bullock moment my life
is just a Sandra Bullock moment
hashtag woke up like this what am I
supposed to do likable oxygen let go
Blake go into the light there's no light
and space dude it's all dark maybe going
to the light go into Earth's orbit oh my
god I'm dying
I need more oxygen who wants to start
the death count I think I'm gonna die
here oh I'm so dead yep this isn't good
I'm suffocating where's where that
drinkable oxygen all right we're about
to die
we're about to die we're about to die
we're about to die that's it that's it
we're blacking out
we're blacking out and not liking a good
like drink come up - whiskey way that's
it oh come on
Oh guys go into the light you know read
by nature I did go to the light I hope
you're happy
why would I turn around I don't know I
was looking for more drinkable oxygen
oh no Liv Oh
press the right stick for environment
scan think you looked away when that
popped up
yes that's true okay here we go Hardiman
it's really close to hungry man which is
the kind of dinner I grew up on um so
anyway if you just missed I bought this
shirt for eight dollars I think it's a
knockoff but here's why I bought it
it's a lot of tactile it's very smooth
then this is all we don't know what's
going on here this is like like a
letterman jacket then there's a bunch of
are these all like Olympic years I don't
have
here then America of course then you get
this a little skin underneath there you
go peekaboo
exactly loves that little just in case I
need to like feel myself up if I'm
lonely at the club you know and no one's
near me I can just yeah this is like my
lonely pocket I call it super stretchy
and then look on the back just randomly
there's a bunch of crap what is
happening here what does it say what
does it say Riley it's like xxxx like
who knows and then we got stars and then
we got this just like the Argentinian
flag I don't know what's happening this
shirts a mess the sureties okay here we
go environment scan by the way I think
it felt bad for me too gave me more
oxygen oh geez
okay here we go whatever this is
oh I don't want to hit that thing away I
think I want this thing right don't swat
at it like an idiot you're a rocket
scientist dude
well I don't know what that thing is hey
there's a fork all right here we go
here we go we're going into the uterus
area sorry I don't know
umbilical sorry I didn't mean your ass I
don't know if he what space or science
so basically it's telling me I'm an
idiot and to stop using the propulsion
so much all right here we go
is there an inside where I could just
take my take my shoes and socks off and
kind of curl up by a fireplace drink a
little rose a does that cannot happen in
this game
oh no it's chaos okay let's do another
scan here we go trying to figure out
what this is why does it keep saying oh
yes oxygen got it
boom hey there's me I got a really big
head I guess it's just my seat
all right where am I going here oh Jesus
let me just at me okay let's get over
this scheme would be sweet in VR by the
way hey a drift guys make this game for
VR it'd be awesome I should sit up
straight I got really bad posture right
now room my back all right fine I don't
know what's happening I'm not quite sure
what's happening with these things oh
here we go got some more oxygen right
here baby
oh yeah oh
fill me up buttercup can I strap any of
these to my belt cool all right going
into another uterus area umbilical area
you know what I'm talking about my
favorite color ah black like my heart I
know it's not a color vantablack is
actually good thing there's all this
oxygen floating around well what am I
supposed to do now whoa here we go
let's get over to there North Star baby
it's already on VR sister Darth woo half
the players in VR next week on stream
coca we have AJ Brooks coming in former
WWE person unclear dude hit the thing
keep me that give me that cash where's
the thing here we go is this Poland
Spring oxygen cuz I only drank Poland
Spring oxygen here we go
this game makes me want to do a lot of
like do you guys ever move around is
there a word for that or like you move
around as you're playing a game like an
idiot
Oh dr. Khalif you know I love some mash
mouth sphincter thank you that's the
proper word I want to look like a douche
now that I'm thin that's true and I'm
succeeding what about me
I don't count well let's go over here
this is gonna be something
right here we go
we got an o2 station baby charge me up
right charge me up hello let's just do
it does this not work
some body once told me don't even get me
started
my friend had that in his wedding by the
way that song it was fantastic so I'm
not just gonna sit here by the o2
station never figuring out how to work
it
that is correct all right I guess it
doesn't work let's go oh there's some
oxygen
ah man that's a lot of dandruff gross
that's real gross ah come on oh geez oh
geez
Ardex blows poop
what's a poop oh come on Perce ki
you love that song you love it it's kind
of the scheme is kind of hard because I
guess you kind of have to choose between
moving and breathing I don't rule Thank
You Phillip for thinking so it's read me
it doesn't work thank you bye daddy whoo
and the chat has played this game
because I'm gonna look to you for some
serious help here
because I am what you call stupid am I
going the right way
Oh stay away from those thingies
ah come on dude
god this sucks
Austin it's not about dragging anything
on it's just about isn't it fun to
constantly constantly worry about the
lack of oxygen and not being able to
enjoy the pretty space yes that's true
you played through this once how was it
hi from Germany
hello kya hello back house in Germany
once and I uh
oh no I met a girl named Chi in France
but she was from Jerry she's very nice
deathcount - hey
Mexico City I'll say hi to Mexico City
love Mexico City ah the place to be -
this game is fun I just suck never
mistake a my clothing choices or B my
lack of ability never confuse that with
how a game actually is we're gonna heard
of this game that's right crispy mean
we'd like to play games
everyone's why we would like to play
some fun indie games that people like
give a little bit of a larger platform
to those small games cuz there's so much
noise out there here and I'm saying it
can't all it's just you can't all play
blockbusters all the time what's the fun
in that I mean I like a Michael Bay
movie as much as the next guy but
especially to that next guy is Michael
Bay himself I should try deadlight
what's deadlight
is that like dead but less fattening
thank you high five to the chats look
it's just dead joe kappa lose in here i
don't want to hear about it alright so
here we go this way i think we're going
the right way
finland malaysia i'm about to take a
test wish me luck mar why what's the
test so i want to go this way right what
are the green hey who played this nile
now exist ence dia what's the greenboxes
what are those about this is a hard game
marshall and also i'm terrible so it
makes it doubly hard when you're dumb I
should make giveaways and give away my
shirts I should it's a good call feeling
rules bazinga
this is Dark Souls 3 the space DLC yeah
the Lord of cinder was in here a few
minutes ago so what is that what what's
the deal there we go oh I see maybe that
oxygen came out of those things so maybe
the maybe the boxes tell me where the
oxygen is coming from
just kidding can't get a handle on how
big oh yeah no
catastrophic really you think so good
there's a lot of stretching all right so
we got to dodge all this crap let's take
it slow because touching this stuff is a
really bad call take it slow take it
slow okay
is what I like to call totally
is that a space term
I'm space screwed here we go
I'd like to grab that oxygen please I'd
like to grab the oxygen please let's go
chugging oxygen like 5-hour energy
that's true great stretching noises yeah
all right here we go
am I going the right way don't dab yeah
man you keep saying that dude what am I
supposed to do just flow it out here
like a dick
there's my tooth there's my fork again a
lot of Forks on this station okay it
takes me like all my oxygen to position
myself to get an oxygen thing which
seems kind of stupid I am reading both
I'm reading everything Callie little
behind on the new Voltron how is the new
Voltron I mentioned I upgrade my scene
get more oxygen and other stuff like
boosts is there are there villains in
this game there's the villain my lungs
is that like is that like the villain in
this game is the fact I need to breathe
seems unfair now which way do I go
so well they got broadband up here
that's dope
stable is a relative term when you
upgrade your boosters navigation becomes
more fun I'm gonna take your word for it
when does that happen
playing like an hour maybe I have to
open the playing container just do bong
ribs is this the right way or am I going
the wrong way here this doesn't look
like the right way but I don't know what
is I'm just floating out into the
atmosphere right now which seems really
bad this can't be right right I should
have gone the other way the villain is
reality as always you're right Andre so
[Music]
right I should be going the other way
everybody yeah I can see my house from
here
this is slow yeah bong rips shout out
always what um I'm I think I'm
dead I'm about to die again cuz I done I
done I done gone the wrong way
I'm playing a Sandra Bullock yeah but
Sandra Bullock was way smarter than I am
I'm playing as the guy who got his face
like smashed off 2 minutes into gravity
actually maybe this is the sequel to
gravity maybe this is what happens when
Clooney floats away spoilers can be
pretty confusing to navigate you can
look at the circle on your left oh all
right oh I see okay the circle oh I see
oh we're getting close to suffocating
gonna be bad things are going dark
things are going dark darkness sucked
down this oxygen we're gonna die here
we're gonna die here
we're gonna die here Reina die here
we're gonna die here we're gonna die
here we're gonna die here yeah we're
dead we're dead we're dead that's it
we're dead
we're dead we're dead that's it oh
there's oxygen yes oh yes sweet sweet
oxygen so oh the sphincter no open e oh
God really go for a space nap right now
that's a nap in space guys technical
term are I supposed to go here
why doesn't my pressurized suit contain
lots of o2 I don't know
but here's some more no - right here
abouts boom alright so this way is the
next way it's a window I don't get where
I'm supposed to go here everything is
messed up
alright I can't well here's another
Oxford - obviously they know that like
you have no idea we were going here cuz
I give just giving me tons of oxygen
Clooney's fine is his Batman suit with
the sweet bat nips
yeah safe well this looks like this
definitely looks like a bear game so I
guess this way ouch we're gonna go this
way I know I went this way before and we
almost died but we're gonna continue
going this way I'm doing something suck
oh sorry Lamesa
so I'm going towards what I think is the
next stop right does this seem like the
right way space you can't ask anybody
for directions guys this doesn't seem
right you know if I would stop panting
like an idiot maybe I wouldn't use up
all my space air that was called space
there it is probably more about the
visual in VR I had to sit down take a
stress pill and think things over I'm
gonna die here I'm dead I'm dead I'm
dead I'm dead dying I'm dead I'm dead
[Music]
hey Josh Garin thank you for calling me
what I am a new I'm not sure where to go
there must be something clot inside the
closest Victor yeah but what what's
behind the sphincter everybody wants to
know Hardiman mankind above all else
yeah right then how about giving us some
real oxygen man oh man
Jarvis adding to the dialogue by just
saying poop I appreciate it
you know I always appreciate that all
right another point of entry yeah T
virus-infected I gotta say all the
deaths in this urn incredibly uh total
Germania I think the objective is to get
a fixed suit
I guess I'm drew no it's just water
we're just drinking water today I'm just
joining us we're playing a game called
adrift with a 1 in it instead of an eye
I'm wearing a really stretchy weird
shirt that has a pocket that just opens
up to nothing it's just skin see it's a
good like chest burster shirt like guys
I'm not feeling too sorry what's wrong
with me it's Monday morning everybody
all right let's go oh you know what it
might have just put me in like a better
area
your mind is going into Brian uh-oh
better go find it the police I'm in is
our digital studio where we do a lot of
our extras and a lot of shooting
yeah biggie biggie biggie biggie here
come on come on
Jesus at ease whoa all right rule you
know pure oxygen gets you hi guys so
basically we just keep taking bomb grips
in this game that's what everybody know
that all right here we go
so I'm guessing on the left where you
can't see is are my objectives actually
brother can you move us to like the top
I can move us to the I guess the top
right might be a better way so there we
go so on the left you can kind of see
there's like arrows and stuff up there
are some scissors I knocked into I don't
know ta go what happened to our
spaceship but it is totally effed
I gotta want it I'm wanting in my dev
the water makes you high too I guess
top-left Siddarth it wasn't the top left
and the people weren't digging it I feel
like we played this part but maybe I'm
crazy there we go
name of this game is bong rips in space
the original name of this game is bomber
space bong rips just getting my ass
handed to me by my own lungs it's pretty
depressing
yeah Mission Control I'd love to talk to
you but I can either thrust or talk yeah
that's what she said I missed one there
were three there what did I miss I don't
have to get every oxygen thing do I
all right we're definitely going the
right way though
see another oxidant thing I'm homing in
on it yep
all right we're doing well guys here we
go on our way to the next one you know
what this game could use is like a
xenomorph if I find Benjamin I find a
common trail of oxygen I'm going the
right direction okay cool
the problem is when I get off the right
direction it's hard to get back on it
the game would have been better yeah I
agree it would be fun to find some
puzzles in this game it may be that's
okay I feel like I'm getting better at
the propulsion though right guys come on
right all right we're back here yeah
it's a floating simulator
I thought astronauts had better cardio
yeah me too okay oh this is something
this is something that's something dope
what is this does that do something do I
put it in here
how do something with this
he's like interstellar can i watch my
kids grow up like 30 years in like 10
seconds and really cry about it amazing
moment by the way I don't know if you
guys have seen the ads for Dunkirk
Nolan's new film but they felt they shot
some of that next to us in the stage 16
and so a bunch of people saw Nolan
walking around in a wetsuit which is
really cool and then I actually saw
Harry Styles come out of a bathroom
dressed in World War 1 dressing for one
hour fake which was like great it's so
weird
we lead a very weird life there's all
these guys sitting outside the stage
like smoking with awe like in World War
one gear and like all these lifeboats
and stuff it was very cool very surreal
but apparently no one likes to use stage
16 the stage next to us
and all the stuff said had a different
name on it didn't say Dunkirk it's it's
something else all right here we go
all right we're definitely guys we're
making progress here I found how or how
to electric Boogaloo do something with
this I put the card in somewhere you
know I just keep going am i doing that
in here cuz it looks like I should be
doing something in here
no but I do see a crazy big thing coming
up Oh see this looks like something cool
oops oops oops oops all right here we go
perfect
is there any oxygen in here though is
very oxygen in here I see some oxygen
here we go I don't know if I'm getting
bent it's like are the cracks growing in
my windshield
let me show my space windshield okay I
just got a human here we go there's a
little flashing thing yeah what do I do
here
can I hit the thing nope you're staring
at a hot girl know what's happening here
alright well that's a bust Hey look my
diploma oh here we go
okay put the thing in the thing dude
commander Oshima I've reviewed your BA
blah blah guarding your alternate
proposal okay yadda yadda yadda yep
stick to your plan close this down bring
it home okay yet the decimal good old
Samuel director Hawking prepared dated
materials my Occident better not be
going down by the way but I seen the
thor ragnarok trailer no I have not
there's a pod with green arrows behind
me okay thank you all right we're done
with this I'm tired of reading this
stuff I'm just gonna read a bunch of
emails I'm dying here all right here we
go there's a pod with green arrows
behind me oh here we go over here yeah
Oh guys we are gonna welcome to a new
show it's called pimp my suit with
what's-his-face who was him who wasn't
pimp my ride it was oh my god the rapper
what's his name it's like a hardcore
rapper whoo girl I'm looking good
all right great
okay now my oxygen is Oh it's when I hit
stuff it still sucks oxygen still going
down so this is a pain in the ass am I
about to see Ben Kingsley dead exhibit
that's right exhibit it's so funny cuz
exhibit is such a hardcore rapper and
then he's like hey we're gonna make cool
coolican cars
this looks so funny what's happening
over here
I gotta take a space nap in here no oh
Sebastian thanks to the push called in a
favorite here to transfer proof from
downer today what am I just like
snooping is this all about like a
jealous ex-boyfriend like trying to find
like like reading is great like
astronaut girlfriend's emails I don't
know look he's speaking French they're
probably doing it as hard as his home
this is how they this is how the t-virus
got it's not it's here iris got to earth
tomorrow I was so fake they made those
cars the last few weeks tops I mean
that's true of course it's also like
those shows like Extreme Home Makeover
like they're not making great quality
build homes I think they're just making
let's get some more oxygen
SpaceX dude I think the people must have
had sex in space right haven't they
haven't they tried to do it don't they
have like handles or something they put
on like clothes with like handles on
them I mean I find kissing girls is hard
enough on earth
of course there's less choices in space
so maybe that favours me you know I blew
up
Malik's ascend see I blew up the ship
just so I could read people's emails
I'd do it by the way right just like it
snoop
my ex-girlfriend I love it don't put it
past me uh you know what I've been
watching that show crazy ex-girlfriend
it's awesome you guys seen it it's
really funny highly recommend I've also
been listening to that podcast s town
which is fantastic as well by the guys
who did cereal it's really good it's not
like cereal but it's awesome all right
we got another one of these things
I'm not going here this thing doesn't
work right
the Evi station still doesn't work still
no worky alright gotta find some oxygen
and fast or we gonna die in here we go
here we go
um I'm we uh drink like Fiji oxygen I'm
sorry imported from the hills of you
know luckily somebody left all these
glowing lunch boxes everywhere for me to
follow
so my suits like leaking again bad I
want to meet the engineer who thought
sharing the oxygen I think they have to
do that though right breathe the blocks
breathe the Box in in for polish and
oxygen maybe not how do they do it in
real space we've had we had Richard
Garrett Garrett on stream cocoa and he
actually went up into space we should
have played this game well I guess this
game wasn't out then need it he's been
to space he could have told us what was
like how bad I am at playing this game
which is extremely bad the love of
anything turn around to go the right way
I'm going the right way
I mean there's more oxygen so I'm
definitely going the right way I just
think that that's maybe like what this
game is no this game is just called
space floaties we don't exactly know
what we're supposed to be doing other
other than snooping on everyone's emails
I wish you could grab a couple bottles
of this oxygen here I just take it with
you
there we go easy does it it's kind of
like operation in space you know you
just got a thread the needle whoops I
want to go down come on dude not cool
not cool all right where's the dumb you
know an interesting thing I learned
about space is a lot of the fuel my
spaceships need so much fuel to get to
skete velocity is not so much
it's a obviously to get out of the
atmosphere but also to make you go fast
enough that you're to get you into orbit
so you're not you need cuz you're
skimming up and around I never really
realized that it takes a lot to go up
but they're actually shooting around the
earth which is kind of do guys are milli
into space you know now that I played
this game for five minutes I'm an expert
tricky life is down for a little space
space sex I don't know man I don't think
it'd be very fun all those fluids
everywhere no thanks
seems like no thank you gonna pass ooh
those crunchy Cheetos cuz I could I
would love space Cheetos although that
would probably be terrible you don't
want some Cheetos in space because all
the powder goes everywhere
follow the Arab following the arrow dude
oh no wait this is the right way is this
not the right way am I going the wrong
way
oh I am going the wrong way wrong way
yeah I am really what arrow on the left
oh I see
oh that arrow oh okay all right sorry
damn it Jimmy now I'm gonna die because
I wasn't paying attention all right here
we go
following the arrow I see the arrow guys
I'm on it
she's probably gonna die here in a
second cuz I wasn't paying attention to
the arrow but you know what maybe
there's an extra Poland Spring oxygen
over here
I've been going the wrong way not the
whole time come on the whole time only
going the wrong way for like five
minutes
oh Jesus Christ ah there's so many
arrows I see right now I see four
different arrows alright well now I'm
going the right way you guys got me
blabbering about fluids in space and
that's what you get don't distract me
with all this space fluid talk for so
long says Connor oh man oh god I'm so
screwed getting the space is relatively
easy says Ebert you need to be going
sideways really really fast obviously
continually falling for the earth and
missing yeah I didn't realize that
because I'm dumb now I get it
here we go I see the ice there's so many
arrows they could make there's like
three white arrows they could make one
of the arrows red you know they wouldn't
be hurting themselves by making an arrow
a different color and by the way here's
an idea for games because this happens a
lot if you're gonna do a tutorial about
how to look up and down how about do you
tutorial about where the f to go you
know that's a tutorial that I would sit
through like if you get lost here's
where to do it it's not gonna ruin the
game for me I love like games are like
hey if you've never played a game before
here's how to move around and by the way
we're not gonna tell you where to go or
what to do the stuff you actually need
to play the game no no we're gonna let
you figure out that stuff the stuff that
would be super helpful will be explained
by yourself alright I am going the right
way right that's the right arrow that
I'm looking at now I've chosen the right
of 16 different arrows the right arrow
alright here we go
there we go we're slowly floating out
man
you know this game could use besides
like a xenomorph and maybe like may need
some kind of like lightsaber
I know nASA has a lightsaber come on
guys we all know nasa's been working on
lightsabers one thing that's actually
kind of cool that i love is it's kind of
cool that like sci-fi authors I'm a big
reader right in sci-fi authors like well
think of something like in the 50s or
something like you know and then us
nerds will grow up well not us because
I'm not smart but people will grow up
and then like make those things you know
like I don't know the internet or like a
tractor beam
like you know somebody's working on a
tractor beam like I love that I love
that people I love that like you know
people are like oh that would be super
cool like with sabers existed so let's
try to make a lightsaber
you know Elon Musk has a lightsaber at
his house we all know that maybe that's
why like coming up these batteries and
Tesla and all that stuff it's just him
trying to create a lightsaber and like
okay well I figured out this new battery
technology for my lightsaber but I guess
we'll put it in cars
am i stoned no I'm just normally like
this I drink a lot of diet coke so I
think I've changed my brain chemistry
kind of like oh kind of like John
Travolta and phenomenon I'm just trying
to like get superpowers by drinking diet
coke
I saw Logan by the way movie was dope
it's being superpowers where's Clooney
we are a Clooney dude get with it
no wait something's supposed to happen I
think in here oh my god I've been going
the wrong way like the entire game
unless I'm following now like a
different wrong arrow oh I don't think
we've been in here
oh here we go
give me the Walkman give me the Walkman
yeah all right did I just throw that
thing wait till I need that thing who's
played this game a clueless gamer Mass
Effect Andromeda would be fun yeah dude
all right well this looks like an
important room so what's up
so what do we do here exactly
here we go
I'm gonna read some more sexy emails
mankind above all else seems a little oh
here we go okay all right you don't have
to tell me everything you're doing just
do it all right so I gotta find all this
stuff this guy sounds like a real square
oh my god the studio is no fun why can't
they make like fun robots you know like
Cortana at least was like hot space porn
Jacob this is the exact opposite of
space porn unless you find reading
manuals erotic which some people do
reminder that Tom Cruise movie what Tom
Cruise movie when I go to space in real
life after playing this game yes
Benjamin I absolutely would I really
want to go to space just working on that
twenty million dollar price tag because
we ain't getting there by smarts you
know so okay all games eventually boil
down to just like follow the arrow or
you know it's like it doesn't it kind of
doesn't matter it's just about it's a
remix of different things you
all right here we go out this doubt the
blue door join it do I know a game
called star citizen now there was a game
by the way there was this game I played
on as a kid or you could choose like
eight different you could choose like
eight different spaceships and you would
like fight with each other
yes the mummy the Tom Cruise movie
definitely looks like Uncharted I'm
sensing a back story coming up this guy
sounds really attractive though this guy
sounds like what's-his-name who played
Robocop Anderson Suicide Squad
Joel something McKinnon okay no you
don't need to swear
alright profanities not helping anybody
pal also what do I do and just throw-in
things around like alright
it's just the right way cuz now guys
there's two arrows here alright am I
supposed to go straight or right or what
laughs I'll take some that oxygen though
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah I mean this game is aptly named you
are adrift alright I guess I'm going
straight or right like knocking into
stuff here
alright you don't need
okay what do you think we go in here
okay Oh
well following oxygen can relieve some
of that oxygen there's something with a
gear on it am I supposed to like fix
that thing
give me that oxygen am I supposed to fix
this thing there's two things I'm
supposed to do okay
am I supposed to do something with this
don't use the same things that's like a
button and this you know what I'm saying
like don't put like the same button
that's not my controller on the thing if
it doesn't do anything guys come on
we're gonna die we're gonna die up here
it's gonna be bad can I make a straight
line to the atmosphere and burn up
that's a good question I might try it
what is that beeping yeah I'm kind of
surprised
this atmosphere hasn't broke or that the
atmosphere hasn't broken this up either
whoa
oh hey keep asking me that I don't know
the answer to that supposin fix the
second escaping the space shuttle it's
start a colony on Mars how am I gonna do
that
without somebody else go towards Earth
to see if I fall in all right I'm gonna
try it let's try it let's see if I burn
up I'm giving it a shot here we go here
we go all right definitely falling
towards Earth by space station I'm
moving extremely slowly towards Earth
yeah let's see if I burn up three days
later I'm still alive I don't think you
can't
I'm really trying guys
they should make at least one animation
where you burn up what are we doing come
on Benjamin I think the overall
objective is oh you can't burn up that
doesn't seem fun oh my god I'm moving so
slowly
[Music]
for Emmett's I want to be a crispy
critter but it's not gonna happen
that sucks what your crap Andy's just
take my helmet off well I wanted to kind
of burn up there's a great if you guys
like web comics there's a great one
called the Perry Bible Fellowship like
my favorite web comic it's all different
and it's super dark and weird and
there's one and normally it's just like
three panels and one of my favorite ones
it's called snowflake and it's basically
like it's like there's a it's like this
there's like two astronauts it's like no
Gary no he's like ah any Falls Anthony
burns up and the last panel is just like
a mom and a child and it goes like and
they there's one snowflake that goes on
a kid's tongue and the mom goes ooh
first snowflake of winter whatever and
it's obviously the astronauts burned up
it's hilarious
people eating people doesn't get any
funnier that's right I can see my house
from there that's right old salty it's a
pg-13 game yeah 2017 to 2017 PBF rocks
yeah you guys Perry Bible fellowships
really funny
why be doing love streaming anytime
again I'm not sure we love streaming is
but I'd love to figure it out
but yes we're gonna we do a lot of live
streaming here we do this every Monday
all right so where are we going kids
let's follow the magical arrow that I
can't seem to keep following some dumb
Chris Goodson I got this shirt for eight
dollars in New York it's got a pocket
that just opens up the skin so that's
fun there you go that's weird uh and
it's got a bunch of weird numbers in the
back I bought your random things I know
I think this is like a ripoff of a crazy
it's supposed to be a ripoff of like a
like a limp exert but it's made out of
like weird stretchy stuff and that's the
Argentinian flag on the side I don't
know what's happening
give me that oxygen oh yeah
so so far we've been floating around a
lot I mean this game is well-named it's
called a drift yeah we're still in the
same game Alvin sorry bro so maybe we're
supposed to go down into that thing I'm
thinking uh we played some Resident Evil
7 that game is real fun and insane in VR
very scary I kind of almost couldn't
even play it cuz it was too scary in VR
yeah there we go
about getting a PC instead play on
console well we've played stuff on PC
confusing sure - greed
alright thumbs up
where's Conan where is the Conan filmed
he is filmed in Burbank California right
here on Warner Brothers Studios very
exciting I saw they also started filming
powerless that show with Danny Pudi
Vanessa Hudgens right by us
does anybody seem powerless well I am
flying now dude we got it moving along
at a good clip I think if I stiff I
dodge the space garbage I actually live
longer
imagine that oh good one good one good
one love it I love crazy robots my
favorite go inside of the hole get it in
the sexy human being
I agree white ops we can't even see
ourselves and we just I think even
though the gloved hands look sexy
alright here we go ah another day
another space finger to get into I pass
a computer what checked out that
computer alright we're going back
you know the computers gonna be able to
help me with absolutely jack so get
ready yeah guess what guess what
smartass computer don't computer no
worky look at that it's like somebody
dropped their iPhone 9 now I gotta suck
up another oxygen because we had to
backtrack just a real spacewalk kind of
darío I think this is pretty accurate to
what a spacewalk would be the heavy
breathing heavy breathing is sexy or
maybe she has asthma yeah maybe she has
space asthma this is working skate for
life any mutts I don't know if there's a
cheat I'm wondering if there's any kind
of achievement in this game it is
beautiful though whoa here we go time to
get high can I just suck up these
bubbles this is cool
the catch is it's all poison ivy Oh guys
triangular-shaped leaves
don't touch it you're gonna get spaced
poison ivy by the way these bubbles are
why you can't have sex in space too many
fluids man it's not good well let's see
the plants are fine even though there's
filly live this is basically called this
is a drift and there's been some kind of
its kind of like gravity that movie
gravity in space there's been some kind
of a horrific disaster and I'm not
talking about this shirt I'm talking
about there's been a horrific disaster
in space and we have to get back to
earth somehow the game is basically
called float around and suck up oxygen
but it's fun I got to say I'm at a good
time the graphics are dope the controls
are pretty great once I got the hang of
them that weed vlad Conan does play
games
um he plays some games does this do
anything up here
blockage detected hello brother I'm
gonna let that one lie let's see here
alright so blockage detected kind of
unblock it we've eaten too much cheese
there's a blockage detected okay what do
we have to do here well so can I not
just open this door
manual clearance required oh whoa look
at this all of a sudden is like the
fountain guys I found the Tree of Life
why is there a giant tree in here
smart idea was that oh yeah be totally
cool man let's just play like a oak you
know dumb Karl always want his trees
accelerated growth chamber
all right that's cool
I mean this seems like a great use of
space and a Space Station but what do I
know do God of War enclose camera god of
war looks dope the new god of war looks
insane I'm really cool and a fun take on
it to win that tree be dead cuz of no
oxygen yes it would that is correct
oh wait wait wait guys I got this dope
card get me into the club so I got extra
bottle around here there no bottles in
here oh there we go guys that's just how
I do you know I just pop bottles bottles
and supermodels that's me mr. cool
astronaut guy
dis gf5 what's that north missile north
mythology's great fit - yeah that's true
groots the pilot I am Groot
all right back out the space this guy
again captain whiney captain I left my
kid at home for no reason and I have to
swear a bunch my god emo astronaut
strikes again I don't know man no was
just like and she told he's out here you
know what's the piano happening why is
her piano
alright creepy music play
Knight is decided by the presence of
sunlight what is the check I look away
for a minute and the chat gets crazy I
spots already eSports teams no I don't
should I find an eSports team might call
them like the Los Angeles pointment I
think white MIT is a memory used word
and if you were going up against a team
called acquaintances you feel like a
gross you know get your head oh wait a
second I think I see Clooney
[Music]
I think we're about to see McDonough
over here
Wow guys it's beautiful look at that Los
Angeles no that's not Los Angeles
looks like India down there oh there's a
concert happening up in space
[Applause]
[Music]
oh I think I just threw something at his
head sorry bro
my bad McDonagh
well I think does kind of EFT can I do
something to him though
sorry McDonough very nice that's it we
don't care about McDonough er bottles
for me
all right bye McDonough what's happening
in here I go in the wrong effing way
again no no I'm going the right way
whoa crazy that's pretty cool again the
graphics against gamer dope wow that's
awesome I am going the wrong way I got
to go back Ryan I've fought on the right
arrow right guys are not being stupid
I found this dig yeah I found this take
top key really I see bottle push his
body towards Earth Viking funeral
Chelsea this game is kind of maddening
I'm not gonna not gonna lie it takes
patience
[Music]
so wait it's telling me to go that way
okay am I supposed to do this thing nope
yep keep banging into stuff that's great
okay I get it just do anything no am I
supposed to do something with his body
oh wait this thing here we go okay let's
get that oxygen friend that oxygen give
it to me let's grab it we've grabbed it
please we're about to die can we please
grab the oxygen friend great job
there's a raid on down precious
commodities is that an EVE online joke
all right so I don't understand what I'm
supposed to do here again why he games
there koi all right all right guys we're
supposed to go out
crap oh here there we go this way I
guess we're supposed to go that finish
for us is you're done I haven't played
an estimate we won't play next week I
haven't actually can I put these plants
to work for me
all right here we go
Oh to leak reduced alright okay great
and I'm gonna do very quick it's just
grab this little bottle over here so
number this game is a lot of like just
reaching for bottles I think you guys
man which is movie played witcher 3 and
we've done a really fun we did a
clueless gamer with witcher 3 it was
awesome and actually I think they put I
saw and somebody sent to me when are you
amazing people sent they put a horror
through Easter eggs star forward with
Conan O'Brien honest is great medical
officers Edwards p.m. deceased scientist
Elizabeth deceased astronaut Lopez
Theresa deceased system specialist oh I
know McDonald
Sebastian deceased commander Oshima Alex
active yeah baby you ain't to see some
me was I just talking about I can't
remember yeah in the game Conan there's
a Easter Egg where you can find a
gravesite of cone a cone
Oberon which is kind of dope which that
which are folks who are very nice put in
there
my god how big is the speciation hit the
bottle super hard dude
that's all I got
what's beat cop our earth is capable of
greater than even the death star in
terms of numbers I don't know what that
means
am I gonna teach coding to play again
any time soon hopefully start working on
a couple things system status Spiritist
mainframe offline vocalist mainframe
offline Solaris mainframe offline
mobilis mainframe offline manual
mainframe repair required for salvus TeV
operation and launch I don't know what's
happening here do outlets we did outlast
already we maybe we should do number 2
we did our last use pretty fun you can
see all that stuff team koco.com / blue
this game what game here's a question
what game do you guys want to see us do
for the next clueless gamer
what do you guys think would be great
this looks like an important sphincter I
mean doorway sorry Aaron first cutting
in VR battle maybe what system is this
game for danger this game is for
the ps4 we're playing it or as a horror
game next time I do like horror games
playing a lot of I just started I just
be resid evil seven and I've been
playing a lot of alien isolation lately
over my own channel twitch.tv slash
blare some music playing now is that
music or is that something that's gonna
is it a buzzsaw that's floating through
Aaron's gonna kill me I don't think I
can open this right oh oh here we go
wait something else is happening Metal
Gear Solid 5 that's affecting drama it
would be fun
question let the feet up forza forza the
steering wheel we've done four is that
that's effect may be funny where your
eyes terminal mainframe online
initializing and switch those gamer
agnostics old-school mortal combat
escape for life Conan is a new oh here
we go oxygen initialize deviate oxygen
repair yes please oh my god
please repair the oxygen be a oxygen
capacity 100% exit PV a diagnostic nice
oh thank god
initializing cerebrum cord diagnostic
sequence all right there we go we got
this guy's we got the cerebrum cord
today core fabrication required we got
to make any cerebrum core I have we the
horror games are good with Conan that's
true now we're just making a new
streamer core finally cerebrum core
fabrication complete repair check out
soma I've played so much as earless the
thing Lotso m''e is it was basically
just a weird chicken robot that I was
hiding from right just a weird rope
chicken rabbit baby whoo I got the drink
coaster that I need to restart the
mission hi your cerebrum chords in
another castle
pray looks dope yeah what games should I
be playing
I've so much more oxygen than guys oh
wait am i going the wrong way again
answer is yes want to go out this way
[Music]
here we go
let's better for entertaining streams
good games or bad games I don't know it
kind of depends I think the only games
that are bad for streams are boring you
good games or bad games can also be good
uh not sure Dan don't know the next one
is very soon though I'm waiting on a
couple things there's a VR dating
simulation what is that I need to know
about that immediately why are there no
bodies flow down we've seen one body I
mean I think that the space station is
just really big and there's not a lot of
more ex-girlfriend emails part of a
narrow space mission director Tetris
stream in on the fun systems us if
you're dating Sam production is behind
there's VR pornography no thanks I don't
want added that's too real man who's not
layering them in the face of failure but
now there's nothing time for disruption
here we go imperative that you follow
protocol if this dude order to meet our
goals ensure the success of the mission
Garak at this thank you your crew
do not let me down and prove your
critics right
oh my god it's a dope oxygen bomb
finally where am I going here
I haven't saw I haven't actually died in
a while
[Music]
my PSN is just blurred it's my last name
impossible to spell ble Yee RT oh yeah
guys I have popping bottles right and
left oh you know what actually I hate to
say this there's no good time to end
this game cuz it's all kind of whatever
but I think that's it for today's stream
I think that's gonna do it
I know floating around has been time
flies when you're floating around and
just sucking down oxygen bottles but
that's gonna do it for day make sure to
tune in right back here next Monday
Pacific noon for AJ Brooks who's gonna
be our guest from the WWE she's also the
wife of CM Punk she's pretty great
she'll be joining us to talk about our
new book and I can follow me on Twitch
twitch.tv slash Turnblad I'll be
streaming on Wednesday night and again
on Sunday night play a little alien
isolation trying to beat that game and
yeah hit us up on Twitter and make sure
to follow us on Facebook and watch the
show tonight who's on the show tonight
Jenna Elfman Oh Dave Koechner who's the
best in Abramson there you go
make sure to tune in tonight 11:10
central on TBS that's it I can't do any
more floating around guys I just can't
do it I'm sorry I'm gonna go have some
real oxygen back in the office and
always remember never forget the boob
pocket we'll see you guys next Monday
rent bag renewed ice cream cup guys see
you later bye
you